So far for every episode, I keep thinking
of this moment from Breaking Bad where Aaron
Paul keeps shouting: (keep getting away with
it clip).
And the person who keeps getting away with
it is Craig Mazin at making such a great adaption
with so many wonderful changes.
This episode has a perfect balance of retaining
the best moments from the game while also
making some necessary and well-fitting changes.
I can go through them chronologically, but
I want to address the biggest and most impactful
ones first which are Joel and Ellie in this
episode.
We all know that their relationship from the
game to the show is much different in that
Joel is more closed off towards Ellie.
This Joel isn’t 100% the same in comparison
to the game and they are making a more real
and grounded Joel for the TV show.
Instead of a superhero who kills like a hundred
raiders and infected throughout the game.
Some people may dislike this inherent change,
but I think it’s necessary for the TV medium
because games have the freedom of not following
logic at all times.
So giving Joel a new characteristic of panic
attacks I think is really well fitting for
this version of Joel.
It makes him more vulnerable and it shows
a weakness that thus makes him more human.
Joel doubts himself and the more he grows
attached to Ellie, the more he doesn’t think
he’s up to the task of taking care of her.
Like I don’t think this is Joel just suddenly
being overcome with age because the Joel we
meet in the beginning of the show is much
more confident.
Instead, these panic attacks are being triggered
by him genuinely being afraid of not being
able to protect Ellie and him kind of seeing
Sarah in her.
This detail about his character is such a
smart point to add that further punctuates
how much he cares about Ellie.
I think their confrontation this episode lands
extremely well because there has always been
friction between Joel and Ellie and this scene
is the climax of that conflict.
Their dynamic up until this point was essentially
Joel trying his best to avoid this type of
scenario.
He didn’t want to become attached to Ellie
given how her mission was what killed Tess,
but the inevitability of their bond is the
most endearing aspect of The Last of Us.
Not the violence and action throughout the
game as people say there is a gross lack of
in the show.
The characters and their journeys are what
makes this story so amazing.
And I may get some hate for it, but I think
Joel and Ellie’s arc is better in the show,
I said it, although it’s not done yet obviously.
But through this road of conflict and slow
build-up of them getting closer, Joel finally
becoming the warm surrogate father is immensely
satisfying.
It feels much more earned here and you can
see Joel throughout the entire episode grapple
with this conundrum.
Whether it be in this explosive confrontation,
or through more nuanced and detailed moments.
Which on that front, Pedro Pascal gave an
insane performance this episode.
Both for him and Ellie’s scene and Tommy’s.
Seeing him break down and be this vulnerable
was really surprising to me because Joel never
really gets to this point in the game.
The show is able to explore a much deeper
character dive of Joel and the journey we
go on with him for this episode is captivating
because of how outstanding Pedro is as an
actor.
And Bella Ramsey essentially matches him at
all times.
Casting wise they have been absolutely perfect
and I saw some people doubt Bella Ramsey early
on and I think she has more than earned the
role of Ellie.
For this entire confrontation and overall
set of events, it plays out differently in
the game.
Personally, I didn’t like how Ellie suddenly
runs off in the video game when she overhears
Joel and Tommy discussing having Tommy take
her.
I feel like or at least in the show at this
point, it would be a very juvenile and impractical
thing to do.
Especially since Ellie running off in the
game leads to Joel and Tommy having to fight
through tonnes of raiders to get to her.
If anything I feel like they kind of used
that plot point in the game to introduce more
gameplay and if it was translated directly
over to the show, then it would have felt
weird.
Bella Ramsey has been very adult-like and
practical and I can’t see her here just
running away.
Because the whole thing she’s afraid of
is being alone and she’d be putting herself
in danger and the loved ones that chase after
her in danger too.
So again, I think the change of having Ellie
embracing the cold reality of Joel leaving
her is more heartbreaking and also leads to
a satisfying moment of Ellie immediately choosing
Joel to take her when he offers her the choice.
This overall payoff is so gratifying because
of the long road it took to get here.
It makes you feel so warm and moved by their
happy scenes together.
Just them shooting targets alone I can watch
for hours and they are such an amazing duo.
They can both hit the dramatic lows of their
relationship while also portraying an immense
sense of love between each other.
For this little sequence or travel montage
of sorts, I couldn’t escape the infectious
happiness that they were constantly exuding.
And although I’ve seen people say that the
pacing really picks up here, I think it makes
for a more tragic ending from that fast pace.
Because Joel and Ellie are finally on loving
terms so the fact that that is suddenly ripped
away from us makes the ending land even harder.
We were just given the most blissful aspect
of the show, so when the creators take it
away from us and it makes the ending even
more depressing.
Craig Mazin could have written a much longer
journey for Joel and Ellie on their way to
the firefly outpost, but I think this ending
is significantly more impactful.
The only aspect about the ending I would have
changed would be to make the encounter with
the raiders be a bit more suspenseful, but
that is honestly a nitpick.
The scene plays out completely fine and anyone
who is begging for more action needs to relax.
Because we did just get one of the best and
most insane action sequences that also happened
to be original in the last episode.
So pacing-wise, there weren't any plot points
the show necessarily skips over by speeding
up their journey a bit.
Along with me seeing people already complaining
about how the show gets boring whenever it’s
just Joel and Ellie out in the wilderness
together talking.
Which again is just wild to me because their
duo is the entire point of the show.
In this episode, the writers also hit all
the best bits for Joel and Ellie’s dialogue
in the game like Joel saying he wanted to
be a singer and earlier on in the episode
where Ellie was trying to whistle.
So it feels like nothing was really left out.
This attention to detail and understanding
of what makes the game great and while also
making outstanding changes really blows me
away.
Because there’s also so many other smaller
changes that made me love this episode more
than I thought I would.
Like the opening of the episode where Joel
and Ellie are essentially lost so they try
to get directions from these natives.
Firstly, I think this offers a more realistic
angle in comparison to the game because there
the time jump drops them off right at the
doorstep to the dam where they meet Tommy.
So it feels very convenient to kind of have
wondered into that situation instead of in
the show where it’s shown that they are
genuinely lost and have been searching for
a while.
Then secondly, the two characters Craig Mazin
introduces here were surprisingly really funny.
Like I love how chill the wife was given the
situation and the contrast between her and
her husband was great.
The fact that this was just a quick one-off
scene is so impressive from a writing standpoint.
These two characters alone could have carried
a much longer scene if they needed to.
Then the next change was the circumstances
of Joel and Ellie meeting Tommy’s group,
and really the entire first 20 minutes is
original but the moment I wanted to address
was the dog scene.
I was not expecting to almost have a panic
attack for this scene.
This moment does feel oddly familiar and I
don't know if I'm forgetting it from the game
or if it’s inspired from elsewhere like
a dog sniffing for drugs, but the amount of
suspense here really hits you like a truck.
Especially since we witness most of this moment
from the perspective of Joel as he’s losing
his shit.
Again tying back to his panic attacks which
is totally justified because I think anyone
in this situation would have probably turned
into a puddle.
So the twist in seeing that the dog didn’t
smell the fungus and reveals Ellie playing
with him was a major relief.
Then for the last overall change that really
enhances the show is the fact that we get
to see Tommy’s community.
We don’t actually get to see this area in
the first game and is an overall great setting
to have all the dramatic moments play out
for the episode.
Along with it offering a good contrast in
the way Ellie has essentially grown up and
has been living her life.
Like the shot of her awkwardly sitting in
the crowd of people watching the movie illustrates
that point really well.
I also want to go back to Joel and Tommy’s
scene since I kind of breezed over it given
I was talking about Joel and Ellie, but this
scene is so much more emotionally pungent
in the show.
Since Joel is being overcome with the fear
of not fully being able to take care of Ellie
and seeing him break down here was so saddening.
And I love how Craig Mazin actually commits
to this scene because before Joel starts recapping
the events of what happened, they cut to Ellie
walking around the square.
Initially, I thought they were cutting away
like in Game of Thrones where Jon Snow is
spilling the beans to his sisters, but here
we actually have competent writers to fully
execute and nail the deep drama that was available.
So thank you.
I said it earlier but the acting from Pedro
is purely astounding.
He honestly moved me to tears in this scene.
And the fact that we go from this to the Joel
and Ellie confrontation is a pure wombo combo
and probably floored everyone.
The next year of the Emmys is going to be
an insane battle between House of the Dragon
and The Last of Us alone.
Overall this episode was another home run
for me and it manages to hit a major emotional
climax while having a great line-up of scenes.
It nails the suspense, the drama, heartbreak,
has a bit of action, heartwarming moments,
and a moving ending that acts as a gut punch
since we just saw the light at the end of
the tunnel.
The next episode seems to be predominantly
flashback driven with Ellie, which I think
is based on the DLC for the first game, so
I wonder how people will treat that episode.
I don’t know if we're going to have another
episode 3 on our hands in terms of audience
reaction.
Regardless though, thank you for watching,
and let me know what you thought about the
latest episode of The Last of Us.